sowohl würfeln einfach mal die neuen 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8
tiger eine flasche wilo für 25 euro l
wollte was geht ab bereits bekommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht's gut irgendwie
verstehe ich das nicht vorgestern war es
so schön angenehm warm und ich hab
gerade das fenster aufgemacht gefühlt
minus fünf grad draußen naja das hält
mich trotzdem ich ab bräuche im video
ist ja klar wieso auch und so habe ich
mich heute gedacht wir setzen einfach
mal meine serie fort 100% zufällig
bestellen ich warte immer noch ganz
gespannt auf das was handy ich hoffe es
kommt morgen an ich bin da relativ guter
dinge wenn man sich dass sie nämlich mal
anguckt kommt bis zum 24
da und das ist fast schon da also ich
glaube es ist jetzt irgendwie in
frankfurt gerade mein handy kommt zu mir
ja ich bin sehr gespannt und freue mich
natürlich drauf also das video wird
nächste woche auf jeden fall kommen
darum geht aber gar nicht ich habe mir
was neues überlegt und zwar mal wieder
auf ebay haben wir ja schon mal gemacht
allerdings geht es heute nicht um
irgendwelche produkte sondern das ganze
ist begrenzt auf youtube möglich also
deutsche youtuber vielleicht auch
amerikanische user keine ahnung weil die
base irgendwie die einzige plattform wo
es viel youtube merge zum weiterverkauf
gibt deswegen würde ich sagen wir leider
nicht lange fangen sofort an lassen nach
oben da für den nächsten part 100
prozent auf ebay bei 10.000 leicht wie
immer ihr kennt das spielt und ich
glaube erklären wie das ganze
funktioniert muss ich auch nicht mehr
wir haben ja ein zufallsgenerator würfel
einfangen und bestellen dadurch so leute
wegen jetzt mal hier auf ebay und ich
gehe einfach mal die you tube trends du
ein bisschen runter und erste den ich
hier sehr felix haller laden
da habe ich mal gespannt den oder den
april
billa box ach so da fällt wahrscheinlich
das ja nie gegeben einfach mal ein dna
und habe mir wirklich produkte wir haben
ihnen lang mal für 200 euro so dass
schon jetzt dürfen wir mit dem
zufallsgenerator eine 4 und wählen
einfach das vierte produkt aus 1234
poster wollte schon immer
9 990 poster also ziemlich recht teuer
so leute den dass auch witzig din a3
poster
ja sie wunderschön aus ich glaube da war
ja auch noch etwas jünger oder in den
warenkorb zu neun euro 99 befinden sich
im warenkorb wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten youtuber und als nächstes
übrigens jemand sieht hier blind
bayerisch bestellen
frank bruce danke für die erwähnung habe
ich ja schon letztes aufs treppchen mal
gepostet irgendwie das war bei mir vor
allem bei dem zeugnis videos die ich ja
mal angefangen habe und dann vielleicht
auch bei den videos das machen so viele
einfach stumpf lag gut sie haben
zusätzlich kopiert vom hitler oder so
aber ich habe so viele videos gesehen da
steht einfach komplett der gleiche titel
lieber mir mit den gleichen smileys und
dann sagen sie nicht weil das ist nicht
meine idee ich habe das von alex das
finde ich scheiße aber würde ich mich
gar nicht drüber aufregen jetzt
weiterhin wir gucken mal ob es was von
dem frank bruce auf ebay gibt
eigentlich könnte ich auch mal gucken ob
es was von mir gibt ja zwei pkw den
scheußlichkeiten ich werde das jetzt
weniges youtuber die mir gefallen würde
würde ich gern sticker mit nehmen mag
ich allerdings nicht deswegen gehen wir
schnell wieder weg demnächst nämlich
gerade gesehen habe ist julian bds was
haben ihr großes monster special und von
julien gibt es einiges anscheinend wir
würfeln einfach mal die 212 julien
berthier shirt ab sony ich muss doch
filtern sofort kaufen ich denke schon
dass sie wird kostet 1 euro so und noch
mal die 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
julien benneteau ist das wohl offiziell
vom word oder hat das irgendwie einfach
selber gemacht hat so jetzt 10 1 julian
beim din a3 bericht clip für deine
youtube-star sagen
verkauft so was jetzt habe ich schon
zwei poster so wir machen weiter und
zwar habe ich als nächstes da gebe es
wie man da gb pullover das wär doch was
david kapuzenpullover größe es 40 euro
das ist eine ansage so dürft ihr nochmal
schon wieder die 5 1 2 3 4 5 t shirt
größe xxs genau nicht meine größe
bisschen zu klein jetzt haben wir wieder
das problem das kann man nur sofort
kaufen ja da muss ich noch mal wir sind
so leute wie wir für noch mal haben wir
die neuen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
dann biegen pullover größe xl tun was
hat jetzt dieses shirt mit derby zu tun
also ich weiß es kann das sein dass hier
am 21 september geboren ist fünf tage
nach mir eine sehr kreative art und
weise seinen eigenen merge zu gestalten
kommen ich schreib einfach mal mein
geburtsdatum braucht also das finde ich
nicht so sagt wir gehen einfach mal
sofort weiter zu babys beauty palace ich
bin ich mal gespannt wahrscheinlich
alles voll mit blut was das denn der
heilige bibel youtube als
schlüsselanhänger
da fällt mir so aus ich finde diesen
mustern schlüssel echt nicht besonders
schön da passt doch viel besser sondern
babys beauty palace schlüsselanhänger
daran wir würfeln einfach mal die neuen
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
liga eine flasche willi für 25 euro wäre
das jetzt wenigstens zehn flaschen würde
ich ja verstehen chocolate cupcake from
below baby loves you wichtig auch jetzt
war eine kurze frage hier an die ich mal
im vorjahr
denkst du dass kauft die irgendwer ab 25
euro wenn sie es auch im laden gibt
führt auch schon teure vier euro oder 5
euro ich weiß es gerade nicht oder ist
dies oddset cup geht vielleicht
irgendwas besonderes
das kann natürlich sein vielleicht war
das ja eine limitierte auflage genauso
wie es mit jesus es da gibt es nur 500
stück von sollte bevor wir jetzt
irgendwelche anderen youtuber noch
suchen gebe ich einfach mal meinen
eigenen namen alex wie jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
günstiger kommt übrigens es ist ja eine
neue ausgabe von diesem rap-stars panini
album rausgekommen und ich dachte auch
ja komm du bist doch bestimmt auch drin
nein wirklich da ist jeder dritte und
ich blätterte dieses heft um so voll mit
erwartungen
so bin ich denn da ist er unter das sehr
und er dass der und der irgendwann war
ich auf der letzten seite und habe mich
immer noch nicht gefunden aber das war
aus der letzten ausgabe so in den
warenkorb hier collected de wir machen
nicht glücklich
ein euro mehr nicht schon ganz schön
viel obwohl gut beisammen hübschen
gesicht kann man das natürlich auch
verstehen sollte nicht das haben wir es
gebe ich einfach mal ein bin ich mal
gespannt was hat er hier gemacht drake
display das höre ich mal besser nicht an
bmx original von leon matera brett
chrapek es tricks heime dessen
musikvideo 1700 euro jungs also ich
finde man müsste er sagen wenn es bmx
neu 400 euro gekostet hat und leon
marschiert kapitäns freak und sammelte
damit schon gefahren sind
könnte man da auch 200 euro für neben
nein spass 1700 euro ist schon viel ich
muss mir das mal kurz angucken vor allem
ob das jetzt wirklich das originale bmx
ist glaube ich nicht so weit
schnell nein es gibt auch nur drei
ergebnisse hierfür und ich habe jetzt
die zwei hier das finde ich echt cool
zehn euro für sein hotel shirt das ist
relativ günstig neuer und wer wollte
schon hör mal habe ich würde sagen wir
gucken einfach mal weiter macht krank
von dem gibt es zwischen einiges so
leute jetzt bin ich mal gespannt contest
eigentlich jemand den finde ich sehr
sehr sympathisch schaue ich aber nie
ich soll ja nicht gerne displays so wir
haben hier die 4 1 234 gadget con
koptische merchandise 23 eur 90 ist
schon sportlicher preis für den t shirt
und nehmen wir mal wie wow und größe l
leute irgendwie leder das foto nicht wie
man das in den warenkorb und ich würde
sagen zum abschluss kommt noch ein
youtuber dran
eine gute idee die lobbys so leute und
wir würfeln die 6123 hier diesen pulli
den finde ich immer noch bis jetzt mit
abstand am coolsten also von dem
merchandise von denen ich weiß gar nicht
ob wir noch kaufen kann ich glaube dass
wir auch somit das erste was die
anwärter rausgebracht haben absolut
sechs genau 2 3 4 5 6
die lobbys bruder von oder postern eur
95 ach so das ist der film ja gut das
ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so ein
schlechter kauf weil ich habe mir den
film auch mal anguckt damals und das war
ja so mit einer der ersten youtube filme
erinnert mich auf jeden fall so auch mit
an meine anfänge von youtube war damals
kam das halt raus das ist bestimmt schon
so zwei drei jahre her
deswegen ist das ganz nett so leute
kleine schnelldurchlauf wir haben hier
einen dena poster was ich wirklich schon
immer haben wollte
juli in berliner drei bericht clip deine
youtube sammlung den hang ich mir übers
bett du schauen wie lupe 25 euro ja
einen eigenen sticker von mir das ist
finde ich das coolste von allen
originale bmx von leon waschbrett
kapitäns heime des ju wir haben noch das
graue shirt und wir haben bruder von
luther und landen insgesamt bei 1805
euro ach so leute warten jetzt muss ich
mal kurz gucken
[Musik]
ich bin leon baby leon marsch guck mal
wie ich mit meinen jungs deine mascha
ich habe sogar schon disler gegeben da
gibt es ja schon zwei bmx bmxer ok
leuten scheißegal das was mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen ist noch
nach oben dafür noch ein paar diese
woche der nächste woche kommt das handy
und wir machen besteht dann noch mal
bestellen ihr könnt natürlich auch
weitere vorschläge noch in die
kommentare schreiben
ich bin sehr gespannt wir sehen uns
morgen vielleicht wieder am morgen gibt
es neues video hat ein schönes
wochenende noch